there there is a new quarterback in
Dallas and this one came as a surprise a
little Saturday night surprise out of
the blue at a time when it appeared that
Andy Dalton had plenty of options to
weigh and would take his time to come to
a decision
because really what else is going on
right now Andy Dalton agrees to terms of
the Dallas Cowboys on a one-year deal
with three million guaranteed worth up
to seven million which means he's
probably gonna have to play and have to
play fairly well to get the full seven
million dollars it's a good deal for
Dallas they haven't had a veteran
presence behind dak Prescott since Mark
Sanchez remember when Prescott said he
learned more as a rookie from Sanchez
than Tony Romo because Romo was injured
and wasn't around Mark Sanchez is the
last veteran who has been helping dak
Prescott so Andy Dalton walks right in
and upgrades dramatically that situation
behind dak Prescott I'm told there were
five teams that seriously pursued Andy
Dalton but none provided Chris a clear
path to a starting job so Dalton looked
at all the situations and he decided the
Dallas was the best for him the best
team of the five that were pursuing him
the best coaching situation with Mike
McCarthy learning more about the
quarterback position and then the best
chance to win and maybe get to a Super
Bowl but although even you know Cowboys
haven't been to an FC championship game
since 1995 but that's okay and then you
lay the foundation to become a free
agent next year and get a starting job
somewhere else because everyone knows
you're gonna hit the market you can be
factored into the planning so that's why
I dalton did it and you know again it's
one of those things that once it happens
you look at it and say that kind of
makes sense we should have saw it coming
even though we didn't see it coming
Chris well yeah yeah you're right but
you know I will say this is something
and you know what are one of our
producers Pete demel it a little I guess
lightest could tell you I'd open this on
my Thursday podcast a little bit
thinking this could be a destination for
Andy dog you know Mike you mentioned it
all the all the good reasons certainly
you know first off Andy Dalton's been
relegated to backup quarterback ville
that's what he is for now
no one's gonna sign him as a starter and
like oh my gosh the you know the fan
base the energy is up we saw
Andy Dalton were a Super Bowl contender
no he's gonna have to take like the long
way back to get into that type of you
know discussion or conversation once
again you know but either way it's a
great move for both sides for Andy
Dalton it's a lot like teddy bridgewater
last year if something does happen to
dak Prescott yes he knows he's been
relegated to backup quarterback bill
like I said but you go to Dallas that
Prescott gets hurt oh man you go on a
playoff run and you know played well in
the playoffs you might get a chance to
be a starter once again let alone okay
if you're not a starter you're gonna
become like one of the highest end
backup quarterbacks in football and you
certainly can make it good looking that
way so it's smart from that angle for
him and then of course Mike we know you
know you said it this Cowboys team is
good we've looked at them as this you
know on the cusp of a Super Bowl type
football team why would you want to risk
your starting quarterback getting her
and the whole team falling apart cuz one
positions gone and they had a shaky
backup quarterback situation so this was
a good investment to protect the the
rest of the roster
the only flaw in Dalton's thinking as it
relates to possibly playing in 2020 is
this that Prescott has four seasons in
the NFL and he's never missed a game so
it's not like he's exactly backing up
someone with a reputation for being a
little rickety it's not like as if he'd
gone to right adelphia and and was
backing up a carson wentz who you can
set your watch by the possibility of
Wentz ending up getting injured because
of his physical style of play another
thing that actually makes Dalton more
attractive and this is a point that I
made on Saturday I spoke to Marvin Lewis
the former Bengals head coach late
Friday afternoon
Lewis was with Dalton for eight years in
Cincinnati and we have recently praised
Cam Newton for the fact that he came in
as a rookie in 2011 and hit the ground
sprinting despite no offseason program
that was the lockout year everybody
thought the young quarterbacks were
gonna stink Newton was great well Dalton
was also great that year we forget about
it he was a rookie second round pick
35th overall in the year with no
offseason program in the year where
everything was rushed and slapped
together and he came in from
GetGo starter week one and let the
Bengals to the playoffs the Panthers
were six and ten with Cam Newton
the Bengals made the playoffs and to the
extent that there isn't going to be the
usual opportunity to get ready for a
season Dalton is going to be in great
position relative to what he did in 2011
to learn the offense and be ready to go
in the event that there are limited
preparations and also Chris here's where
we cross over into the dak angle in the
air he doesn't sign a long-term deal by
July 15 and decides to exercise his
prerogative to hold out of training camp
and stay away through that until the
start of the regular season Dalton is a
guy who can come in and run the offense
through training camp that's exact I
think that's another big part of the
reason why you signed a guy like Andy
Dodd you're right you know when you have
inadequate backup quarterbacks on your
football team right and the starter's
not there the team can fall apart it can
the practices don't go as well you know
the coaches can't implement certain
plays and schemes because they go whoa
you know our guys not ready for this or
you know he's physically not as good as
our starter so while you know we can't
practice that play you know he's not dak
Prescott he can't make that throw
consistently we have to start to call
plays a different way to make offense
look better and practice around this
type of quarterback and with this with
any dog know you know again as he is
talented as dak Prescott certainly not
but it's not far off and you can still
run the same offense to where you're not
gonna have to worry about oh man I can't
throw as many 20-yard out routes now
that dak Prescott is out of the ballgame
no Andy dog will be able to do that in
practice and certainly like you said you
know has played a lot of football in
this league it's had a few PI off five
but five playoff appearances and
certainly you know knows how to practice
and lead a football team and I think
that's probably what Jerry Jones and
family saw about Andy Dalton and the
value of bringing a minute as well
Dalton's best year was 2015 from the
standpoint of his own performance and
team success and they were on a
collision course with the Broncos for
the number one seed in the AFC Dalton
broke his thumb two weeks earlier trying
to make it tonight after an
reception against the Steelers the
Broncos with AJ McCarron lost or excuse
me
the Bengals with AJ McCarron lost the
Broncos on a Monday night late in the
regular season
Bengals finished 12 and four Broncos
finished 12 and four patriots finished
12 and four Bengals by virtue of the
tiebreakers finished third of the three
and had to host the Steelers that was
the year of the crazy late game personal
fouls that allowed the steel to win a
game that the Bengals had in the palm of
their hands and that was dalton out
because of the broken thumb but that was
the year that they really were ready to
be an elite two that would forget it
because they didn't last long in the
postseason but that was kind of the peak
and since then they haven't been back to
the playoffs here's an angle though
Chris and you mentioned it you mentioned
the gap between Andy Dalton and dak
Prescott and look this is all just
supposition speculation let's have some
fun because we're getting toward I don't
want to start saying the slow time
because then it becomes the fourth all
right I remember distinctly back in 2017
Washington was in position to use the
franchise tag on Kirk Cousins a second
time the value 24 million just about
they'll say I'll Colt McCoy on the
roster he was due to make three million
that year and there was a debate a very
spirited debate within the organization
as to whether or not Kirk Cousins is
eight times better than Colt McCoy and
whether or not dollar-for-dollar McCoy
represents far better value for
Washington than Cousins cuz no Cousins
was not eight times better than Colt
McCoy now here we are three years later
similar argument to be made Andy Dalton
with a three million dollar floor and a
seven million dollar ceiling
dollar-for-dollar is he better than dak
Prescott at thirty-one point four
million Cris your thoughts
well yeah it's interesting thought
listen like to sit here to go apples for
apples right and just go oh
Oh dak Prescott is four times better
than Andy Dalton because of the contract
number no I'm not going to agree with
that statement
I'm not he's not four times better he's
maybe you know a person than a half
better a quarter you know one and a half
times better but that half times we're
talking about is a huge leap in the
difference between what I believe to be
a quarterback who can get you to the
playoffs and then also flirts with that
phrase Mike that I like to use with guys
like Andy dog
you know he's not gonna lose your games
he's not gonna win you a whole lot of
games either
but that half time better football
player we're talking about dak Prescott
I think ultimately can lead you to a
Super Bowl and there's a Super Bowl
champion type quarterback and that's why
he's worth four times the amount of
money as far as what it is in the in the
checkbook of the Dallas Cowboys or the
eyes in the NFL so I don't look at this
in any way as a threat to dak Prescott
or anything like this I think dak
Prescott is a talented football player
who's just reaching the pre the peak of
his prime and then also mike has all the
intangibles that I'm not sure Andy
Dalton has right that's the big question
I mean we saw Cincinnati losing playoff
games you never see him get mad yell at
anybody be a leader that way dak
Prescott we know has those type of
things and is like the alpha male in the
locker room and the guy who does
everything right to give the team the
right juice and energy in a day-by-day
basis and that's why you're paying that
premium car price tag for a guy like dak
Prescott I hope that answered it okay
now I'd say it does and look I'm just
trying to examine this and explore this
from the Cowboys perspective when right
are convinced that they have a great
team now their defense was more flawed
last year than anyone realized going
into the season but still the idea that
the Cowboys under the leadership of dak
Prescott were eight and eight and blue
what should have been a no-brainer NFC
East championship at some point that's
got to stick to dak at least a little
bit at some point you have to because it
would stick to any other quarterback
right eight and eight with Ezekiel
Elliott Amari Cooper that offensive
not as good as it was a few years ago
but still better than average a defense
not as good as it was supposed to be but
still in that realm of average they
should have won that division they
should have made it to the playoffs and
if you are Jerry or Stephen Jones at
some point at some point I'm not saying
that you come to the conclusion that
Dalton is your guy because I doubt that
they will I highly and seriously doubt
that they would ever seriously entertain
it but at some point don't you at least
sit around like we are and have the
conversation what would the team have
been last year if Andy Dalton had been
the quarterback would it have been 8 & 8
9 & 7 10 and 6 7 & 9 what would it have
been and here's where it gets
potentially fascinating and again the
chances of this happening Chris are very
very slim but given that dag Prescott's
agents are playing extreme hardball with
the Cowboys and they want 45 million a
year in the franchise tag when you look
at it year-to-year 35 million a year is
justified the one weapon the Cowboys
still have the nuclear option and we've
only seen it happen three times since
the franchise tag was put in place the
Cowboys anytime they want before dak
Prescott accepts the franchise tender
they can rescind it and apart from
whether or not they would back would be
screwed if they did who's giving him 31
point four million at right now in early
May or later let's say they just wait
until after July 15 they can't work out
a long-term deal they say you know what
dak go be a free agent you don't want
what we're offering you go get it
somewhere else no one's giving him
whatever the Cowboys bottom line offer
is July 15 if he says I don't want it
and they strip the tender no one else is
coming close to that given the money's
been spent the depth charts are set and
we're in the middle of a pandemic yes no
no I mean I'm not gonna argue with you
there you're right I mean they certainly
can play that strong - strong leverage
type play they could and and dak
Prescott would be screwed - what you're
saying and be like Cam Newton nobody's
gonna want to bring them in all the all
the seats are filled right now you know
we know the starting quarter
every team the drafts happen so you know
the Gala's cowboy certainly could screw
over dak Prescott that way yes and make
life very hard on them but I think that
decreases their chance of winning a
Super Bowl I do and then you know you
just make an investment in a guy like
Amari Cooper and then draft a CD lamb
but the pic 17-2 the draft you know I
think to maximize those type of things
that Prescott's the guy to do that he's
a special talent that way there's a
reason nobody wanted to trade for Andy
dog or do any of that because yes we
know the bangles were going to release
them but if teams were really like wow
wait we think this guy we put them in
our system in our city with our team we
think he's secretly and a Super Bowl
type quarterback that would have
happened but nobody did that and that's
where again I'm not sitting here trying
to say dak is four times better than
Andy Dalton whether he's two times
better or you know one and a half times
better that's still a huge difference
and the difference of being a
quarterback that you know I think
ultimately could get you to the playoffs
compared to a quarterback that I think
is a Super Bowl winning type quarterback
in talent and leader well no one was
gonna pay him seventeen and a half
million to be the starter and yeah look
at seventeen and a half million in
today's market that's a bargain
right if you're not willing to pay
seventeen and a half million to Andy
Dalton to be the starter you don't want
him to be your starter because he's gay
and this gets back to the whole you know
the the bookie needs to be driving a
Cadillac theory you have to have a nice
car you have to have a nice contractor
your teammates aren't going to take you
seriously 17.5 million what you you're
gonna get you if they if they would
rescind the tender on dak Prescott and
make Andy Dalton the starter at a low of
three and a high of seven how are those
guys in the locker room gonna view Andy
Dalton well yeah exactly right they're
gonna you know as soon as he makes a
mistake they're gonna be at one that's
why we're paying of seven million
dollars I mean he's a backup quarterback
you're right it'll it'll undermine that
to the team in general you know and then
hey let's you know we also the
conversation with Andy Dalton to like
that's a valid point exactly right you
know I hear a lot of people like why
didn't the Patriots sign them why didn't
the Jaguars sign them hey everybody's
got to get this through
the Patriots are going ahead with their
plan as scheduled this was their plan
Jalen stidham's the plan
they weren't caught off guard by like oh
no Tom Brady left us and we don't want
pancer down and we don't know what to do
no they drafted Jared Stidham last year
because they knew that this was coming
close with Tom Brady so that's why Andy
Dalton's not there the Patriots plan was
to move on with Jared Stidham the
Jaguars that's another interesting spot
for Andy Dalton like because Jay
Gruden's there right but I think
ultimately they think they have a
diamond in the rough with Gardner
Minshew and they want to see how that
goes and they don't want a guy like Andy
Dalton going down there and kind of
hindering that development so well Andy
Dalton's gonna have to learn his way go
ahead what what well I think that I
think that I don't know this but I think
the Jaguars would have been one of the
interests of teams I think Dalton didn't
want to go between the Cowboys and the
Jaguars Chris come on it's a no-brainer
you're taking well sure okay place
that's that's where you want to go and
you got a better chance of playing in
Jacksonville but you don't have a better
chance of coming out of it looking like
a guy who's gonna get an opportunity to
start next year if it is in Jacksonville
you got a better chance to do it in
Dallas we got to take a break one last
point though that I want everyone to
just kind of file away as Jerry Jones if
he goes down this path of rescinding the
tender you look for things that you can
use as justification for your decision
consider this you save twenty four point
four million in cap space that can be
immediately carried over to next year
and next year very well may entail a
shrunken salary cap or that twenty four
point four million may come in handy for
the Cowboys just one of those little
facts that if the Cowboys start thinking
along those lines
I'm not saying I'd be stunned if it
happened but I think we'd be derelict in
our duties if we don't at least put a
flag in the ground of the possibility
that the Cowboys do something good job
for three with you
well done
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports